We do almost everything online these days
because it’s more convenient: shopping,
banking and even dating, you do that.
So why don’t we vote online?
Hey DNews, Jackie here!
In 1999, then-President Bill Clinton asked
the National Science Foundation to look into
the viability of online ballots.
And the committee found that internet voting
systems quote “pose significant risk" and
that quote “E-voting requires a much greater
level of security than e-commerce -- it's
not like buying a book over the Internet."
And now, 17 years later: it’s still just
not safe.
No, your life isn’t in danger by voting
online but your vote is.
Because cyber security is still so fallible,
there’s no way to be certain that our elections
haven’t been tampered with if we vote online.
And even if we eventually figure out that
someone did mess with it, by that time it’ll
be too late for that election!
If you bank online and buy things online,
aren't those transactions safe?
Unfortunately, no.
Banks, credit card companies and online retailers
lose billions of dollars a year due to online
fraud but you rarely hear about it because
if consumers believed that their data wasn’t
secure, the online market would collapse.
Instead, the company either absorbs the loss
itself or passes it down to you via fees and
maybe higher prices.
Fraud online often starts with pulling your
name, credit card info and other personal
information.
And one way they do this is with malware.
One of the most famous recent cases comes
from the malware named Zeus.
The program is designed to wait until you
connect with your bank and then use those
credentials to transfer money out of your
account.
It doesn’t matter if you have a secure connection
because the malware is already inside the
computer.
In 2014, the FBI announced that it had disrupted
the GameOver Zeus botnet but not before $100
million was stolen from accounts around the
world.
If they can do that, it’s not hard to think
that hackers could do the same thing when
it comes to voting!
Malware could vote on your behalf or even
change your vote.
McAfee, the security and antivirus company,
notes that financial or espionage motives
were involved in 89% of online security breaches.
They believe that the hackers are usually
criminals who are looking either to profit
personally or on behalf of nationstates looking
for political leverage.
That is exactly what security experts fear
the most: an inability to truly control an
online voting system where elections could
be determined by someone other than the voters.
That being said, there is one country that
relies on online voting: Estonia!
They succeed by using a government ID, with
a chip, and associated PIN code AND a card
reader for your PC.
Voters can track their vote with an app, and
parts of the software are available for public
inspection.
Estonians can also vote as often as they want
but only their last vote will count.
This minimizes the chance that somebody forced
their vote.
Estonia believes their system hasn’t been
compromised, but security experts argue that
just because their system hasn’t been interfered
with yet, doesn’t mean that it can’t or
won’t be in the future.
Independent assessments of Estonia’s online
voting system, done in 2011 by the organization
Verified Voting, and in 2014 by researchers
at the University of Michigan, found that
voters’ privacy as well as the servers used
were vulnerable to attack from anyone or anywhere.
The UMich report said there were quote “staggering
gaps in procedural and operational security,
and the architecture of the system leaves
it open to cyberattacks from foreign powers,
such as Russia.”
While the Estonian government disputes this,
it still makes a lot of people nervous.
But, why can't we just copy their system?
Estonia also uses a national ID card, something
the US doesn’t have.
Estonia has about 1 million eligible voters,
the US has over 225 million eligible voters.
And to be frank, elections in the U.S. are
more closely watched around the world… both
by citizens and hackers.
Security for a US election would obviously
be much more complicated to say the least.
On top of that, voting is supposed to be anonymous.
And right now we don’t have the technology
to track the integrity of anonymous ballots.
In the end, it seems like the system we have
now is the one that works best and appears
to be the most secure.
Here’s hoping we never have a repeat of
those hanging chads from 2000 -- if you don't
know what that is… oh my god.
It's about paper ballots.
They would get stu--- you know what, just
Google it.
But does your vote actually matter?
Our sister network Seeker Daily tackles that
question right here.
What other questions about voting or the science
of voting can we break down for you?
Or are you just sick of the election?
Let us know down in the comments and don’t
forget to like and subscribe for more Dnews.
Also go vote!
Right now!
Run out and do it!
Yay voting!